alors malgré tout cela le sommet des
pays membres de l'union européenne s'est
ouvert dans un climat qualifié de
consensuel par le président chirac déjà
la charte des droits fondamentaux de
l'union européenne a été proclamée
jusqu'au bout les partenaires européens
en discuter tenez il a fallu
l'intervention personnelle du prévenu me
nice france et pour que tony blair
accepte l'inclusion du droit de grève
dans cette charte européenne les
dirigeants européens ont promis aux pays
candidats à la vision de tout faire pour
tenir leurs engagements et de les
accueillir à partir de janvier 2003 des
propos tenus à la fois par jacques
chirac et lionel jospin dans une
cohabitation parfaite reportage
véronique saint-olivier didier rancoeur
jacques chirac est perdu on ne sait pas
si lionel jospin dit à vos souhaits mais
depuis ce matin le président de la
république et le premier ministre
affiche une entente parfaite
une parenthèse dans la cohabitation
affrontements et l'image d'une
présidence française unis alors que
démarre des négociations internationales
difficile même si le premier ministre ne
résiste pas à la tentation de se montrer
le plus galants une première réunion
avec les quinze partenaires et les
presses candidats l'union européenne
pour parler de l'avenir de l'europe avec
la signature d'une charte des valeurs à
laquelle tous doivent souscrire
officiellement le consensus est parfait
pourtant la présidence française ne fait
pas l'unanimité et les journalistes
étrangers rapportait de grogne la
rivalité grandissante entre le surgir à
quel sujet spa les a pris trop d'énergie
il n'avait pas assez de temps de
s'occuper d'europe on a toujours l'idée
que la france est en vente alors même
s'il n'est pas on pense toujours qu'elle
va y être arrogant il ne faut jamais
croire tout ce qui est écrit
c'est à l'issue de ce travail que je
pense comme d'habitude un juste regard
sera posée sur les choses et peut-être
sur les hommes
jacques chirac et lionel jospin savent
tous les deux qu'ils ont un intérêt
commun à réussir le sommet de nice
du coup le premier ministre n'hésite pas
à apporter un soutien public au
président de la république son nom
d'accord donc on lit presidency de la
république française
et ils présidente de la commission de la
cet accord portait sur l'apprentissage
des langues étrangères et lionel jospin
s'exprimait en italien